sciences humaines comment sont si vous
le voulez bien par parler du coronavirus
et l'ondé de choc ne finit pas de se
propager
les frontières se ferment les aéroports
aussi la tension monte le système
économique mondial est en danger alors
même que objectivement pour l'instant
peut-être que cette maladie n'a pas tué
tant de gens que ça peut-être qu'on en
parle trop avant de
recueillir votre opinion je vous propose
d'écouter un porte-parole de du
ministère de la santé chinois qui chaque
jour et graines presque nom par nom
le nombre de victimes d'un millier selon
roubaix les angels dubaï et je parie
signature d'un millier arrêtées au jury
selon robert bareille de paris cédant
seront bien sûr j'ai tiré s'ils ont
rouvert si ogier les avril et relis et
l'indien tient ici
reina 15 e coli qui donne bien des
fusions line barry seal ont trouvé la
bactérie triple jeu de mémoire il ya 1
milliard 400 millions d'habitants en
chine
est ce que c'est vraiment indispensable
est utile de faire comme ça ce second
point de vue exotiques exhaustif pardon
ce point de situation plutôt ça ne vous
aura pas échappé nous sommes en 2020
donc du bon goût non il paraît donc du
coup les méthodes de communication pas
selon le calendrier chinois voilà ma
solange a donc dacos et voilà on est
obligé de dire tout ça parce que c'est
l'époque de la transparence notamment
dans notre bel hexagone la transparence
a toujours été demandé par la population
le législateur hafidi loi et c'est
notamment après l affaire du sang
contaminé qui a laissé des traces ou des
affaires de santé publique majeur comme
l'amiante et c'est tout ça donc du coup
quand il arrive une épidémie maintenance
et voilà on dit tout on dit tout et on
cache rien alors oui en effet ça peut
alors c'est votre question aller à deux
étages en fait parce que si on dit trop
on entraîne une forme de psychose il ya
des gens qui ont peur d'âge en est tous
les jours au téléphone au samu très bien
si vous dit rien vous entraîner la
psychose et les complotistes qui d'un
coup vous dit ils vont dire liste nous
cache tout on nous cache tout ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'à pas à mon sens il ya eu
au cours d'histoire d'humanité des tas
de petites pandémie comme ça qu'on eu
lieu et qui passait sous la ligne de
flottaison de la connaissance de la
science maintenant avec les progrès
considérables qu'on a fait bas on est au
courant
il y a voilà il y à un virus qui est
sorti
est arrivée qui se répand et c'est alors
vous allez voir ça va se calmer dans
temps dix quinze jours là on arrive au
sol d'ailleurs il commençait à le dire
ça y est on arrivé un plateau et puis
après ça va redescendre en effet vous
avez raison c'est alors la science est
formidable c'est formidable on a des
virologues notamment en france des
biologistes qui sont absolument
remarquable on sait qu'en gros quelqu'un
de contaminer va risque de contaminer
deux personnes d'accord que les cas il
ya des choses qu'on ne comprend pas mais
les enfants semblent plus protégés que
les adultes et ceux qui meurent bah en
fait c'est ceux qui sont souvent
atteints de maladies chroniques de
broncho-pneumopathie chronique
obstructive d'insuffisance cardiaque et
ce terrain là en france
aujourd'hui vous avez eu plus de morts
par la grippe saisonnière hexagonal qui
tue chaque année cinq à dix mille
personnes les années les pires d'accord
cette année elle est moins forte parce
qu'on pense que les grèves ont empêché
en fait la transmission du virus dans
les transports en commun non mais c'est
vrai c'est la réalité
vive les grèves on a évité l'épidémie y
en a fait on a fait des économies à la
sécu c'est formidable
voilà c'est bien cela mais il ya plus de
morts donc de la grippe
aujourd'hui et des actions du travail et
puis vous avez plus de risques en allant
au ski d'avoir une fracture de chute de
ski que de chauffer mais cette
inquiétude qui est diffusée par cette
information est ce que vous arrivez à la
calmer vous disiez en eu au téléphone
donc au samu où vous travaillez vous
avez des gens qui vous appelle et vous
pouvez les rassurer où ils disent non
non j'ai quand même on est entre nous il
ya personne n'y a qu'à faire mais
d'accord non mais on a eu des cas
absolument complètement complètement fou
j'ai croisé un asiatique vite venait me
chercher j'ai peut-être attrapé la
maladie
une autre dame qui hébergeait une
étudiante chinoise chez elle l'a enfermé
dans la chambre pour pour nous dire
venez la chercher enfin là tu voulais tu
dis c'est complètement inconsidérée mais
on arrive ça on arrive à les allées
gérer mais c'est un petit peu c'est un
petit peu peiné mais en même temps si
vous voulez moi le standard du samu de
paris quand même le standaard qui
regroupe tout paris donc six millions et
demi de personnes dans la journée
d'accord un peu plus de 2,3 millions la
nuit vous voyez le nombre de gens qui
ont peur et tout oui c'est important ça
nous fait rire et c'est assez gênant
pour le quotidien parce qu'il ya le
quotidien faut pas oublier sa messagère
salle cher alors ce qui est intéressant
à gélinas et que pour les internautes
qui nous suivent et qui réagissent sur
twitter comme chaque jour il n'y a pas
de questions fusent actuellement la
réponse est claire on leur demande
faut-il une transparence absolue
concernant le coronavirus c'est oui à
95% est dire l élection de sigen
pigments schéma de débat mais la
politique en soi elle ne demande pas une
transparence absolue il y a dans
certains domaines des zones qui doivent
rester rester grise une certaine époque
même le mensonge peut aider comme ça
s'ils mentent et à cimenter la nation
là c'est différent on est sur une
affaire de santé publique et on le sait
quand on quand on ment on discrédite on
discrédite vraiment la parole politique
et ça peut donner lieu à des dérives
alors on parle de théorie du complot ou
en tout cas théorie du complot ça serait
pas le bon terme pour reprendre ta
gueule en fait ça serait les mentalités
complotistes parce que des complots y en
a en fait et les gens les français le
savent il ya patrick leloup le rappeler
il ya une époque en france où on avait
justement tendance à mentir plus qu'à
tomber dans un excès de transparence on
nous expliquait que le nuage s'arrêter à
la frontière et c'est exactement
donc c'est normal qu'il y ait de la part
des français peut-être pas une
inquiétude mais en tout cas une volonté
de vouloir rester de vouloir rester
informés et puis à l'heure d'internet
tout finit par se savoir
donc même si vous voulez un petit peu
aseptisé la réalité d'une manière ou
d'une autre ça ressort maintenant il
faut rester je pense qu'il faut rester à
la fois prudent et même quelque peu
optimistes quant aux réactions des
français en général il ya je pense à un
chercheur qui s'appelle pablo serving si
je
trompe pas qui explique ta fait une
étude un petit peu sur les catastrophes
et la réaction des gens face aux
catastrophes
plus on se rapproche de l'épicentre
d'une catastrophe plus les phénomènes
d'entr'aide sont nombreux c'est vrai et
ça c'est important de le garder de le
garder à l'esprit et la société
politique par essence
qu'est-ce qu'elle a pour but elle a été
créée pour ça pour développer voilà des
phénomènes d'entr'aide vous là je suis
complètement d'accord c'est les
phénomènes de 2,2 quand il ya eu des
attentats notamment du 13 novembre 2015
à paris où les gens ouvraient leurs
portes et attraper des gens qui
couraient dans la rue pour l'épauler
réfugiés bien sûr
jacky isabello vaud qui était un esprit
original comme tous ceux qui sont ici
d'ailleurs mais ce que vous auriez envie
de défendre un avis contraire non
j'étais partisan de la transparence
absolue non d'ailleurs je te prendre
sous l'angle de la de la communication
le cap elle la notion d' alerte chez
nous est très importante
quand on travaille sur de la
communication de crise on se dit
toujours faute il déclenche l air tout
pas puisque l'alertent générer un
surplus d'informations et pendant très
longtemps on s'interrogeait sur faut-il
ou pas la désormais avec les réseaux
sociaux il n'ya plus de questions je
vais vous raconter rapidement un petit
exemple on a débriefé il ya quelques
semaines m'a fait rare et ex comme on
dit avec des spécialistes de la
préfecture des communicants des
officialités catastrophe sur la
catastrophe de lubrizol
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé à lubrizol
le préfet à gérer d'un point de vue
tactique parfaitement bien la situation
ils ont d'ailleurs sauvé des centaines
de vies saines c'est pas su parce que la
communication autour de lubrizol a été
une catastrophe et notamment pourquoi
parce qu'à un moment le préfet s'est dit
je ne vais pas déclencher les sirènes
parce que toute façon les codes de
sirène les gens ne savent pas ce que ça
veut dire
il ya un code de sirènes on devrait
l'apprendre il dit ça va aller [ __ ]
dehors il faut surtout pas les mettre
dehors et qu'est-ce qui a pris la main
et dans les réseaux sociaux les gens ont
commencé à faire fuiter des photos de ce
fameux nuage noir et les spécialistes
qui l'ont ils ont dit attendez il ya pas
de problème comme il n'ya pas de vent
les molécules mortelle si elle était
restée près du sol avec le vent ont tué
des centaines de personnes la forte
heureusement il ya du vent elles sont
parties à plusieurs centaines de mètres
donc n'alertant pas la population
personne n'a dit mais les gens vont
percevoir une catastrophe dans leur tête
ils vont provoquer un sur accident donc
aujourd'hui et moi j'ai écrit plein de
trucs dès le début du qoran un virus en
dix ans les pouvoirs publics doivent
faire ce qu'on appelle de la
gesticulation nécessaire aujourd'hui si
vous n'êtes pas là avec l'objectivité
nécessaire et la puissance qui est celle
des scientifiques et bien ce sont les
réseaux sociaux et pas forcément que les
complotistes des gens qui ont peur et un
dernier point je vous soumets docteur
pelous et j'ai dit attention à
l'arrogance scientifique
pourquoi parce que quand vous avez des
grands sachant qu'ils arrivent qui vous
dit cc avec vos questions bêtes non la
question bête elle est un acte citoyen
quand on dit aujourd'hui les gens ne
vont même plus voter quand les gens vous
appelle pour vous poser une question qui
vous semble bête c'est pas plus bête
qu'un bac + 12
normalien qui vous pose une question à
la con sur la façon dont on fait un
screenshot avec un avec un iphone donc
il faut tout prendre tout ça en question
il se dire il va y avoir des tas de
questions
elles ne seront pas des questions de
sachants il faut véritablement les
traités et que tous les outils ce qu'on
appelle les dark souls donc tout ce
qu'on met en place pour préparer les
catastrophes qui sont pas sur le web et
vous activer des cas une catastrophe eh
bien il faut prendre en compte toutes
ces questions qui sont des questions de
citoyens des gens qui sont pas
spécialistes de la pneumopathie chez pas
quoi qui sont des spécialistes de la
logistique de l'économie du journalisme
et de l'aspect boulga co vient de la
paperasse du journalisme et qui sont pas
des spécialistes des maladies et donc ça
c'est très important dans ce je vais
terminer par un bon point eh ben je vais
vous dire autant ils ont mal démarré
autant je trouve que les pouvoirs
publics français se débrouille plutôt
pas real ils ont mis en place toutes les
bonnes conférence de presse il
communique énormément avec l'objectivité
nécessaire et on arrive à pas faire
paniquer ou en tout cas pas diffuser des
informations qui pourrait être
perturbante dans l'opinion publique
avant d'écouter faire gagner quelques
points de vue d'internautes par izia qui
nous dit qu une totale transparence est
la bienvenue car ce virus concerne de
plus en plus de gens vivent en dehors de
la chine claudius de la transparence oui
mais bien expliquer pour ne pas affoler
inutilement les populations kriss kross
qui nous dit qu'un dissident chinois
parle en réalité de plus d'un million de
cas et de milliers de morts donc qui met
en doute cette communication officielle
de la chine
philippe se demande combien de morts vos
services sera-t-il capable de traiter
par jour sans exploser c'est une
question un peu de théorie nan c'est pas
notre g pour apprendre mais c'est une
bonne c'est une question pour faire su
laisser les scénarios ont été pensés en
fait la stratégie qu'on a à l'heure
actuelle c'est que des quais un quart
une suspicion de cas il est pris il est
mis dans un réseau de soins et isolées
donc en fait ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
des barrières en fait donc on a un
système de barrière si jamais on
dépassait ça a été le cas avec le fameux
l'hypothèse qui a été négative des
enfants à l'école
en fait on ferme l'école et on teste on
teste nous alarmons tej on teste tous
les ans fin mai mais en gros en cas de
débordement ça serait de la gestion de
masse en fait donc d'un coup
probablement comprendrait un ou deux
hôpitaux et on dirait voilà ils sont
tous regroupés l'as monaco recevra 2 en
10 jours comme en chine non mais là
encore si vous voulez si le virus était
aussi virulent est aussi violent et
dangereux que ça a à l'heure qu'il est
on n'en serait pas là d'accord donc ça
c'est ça c'est ça qui est intéressant
je rejoins ce que vous disiez il n'y a
pas de mauvaises questions si les gens
ont des questions à poser les appelle le
samu ils font le 15 et en fait on
l'aurait fait ghana diarrhée votre point
de vue je pense qu'il faut aussi
rappeler d'où vient cet exercice chinois
qui consiste à déballer tout les
chiffres des délits team il faut quand
même rappeler le contexte politique
c'est à dire que le pouvoir chinois au
début a tenté d'étouffer la propagation
du virus en discréditant les notions d'
alerte y en a un qui est mort il ya
quelques jours qui a suscité une vive
émotion sur les réseaux sociaux et d'un
moment la presse chinoise
donc cet exercice de communication
officielle est aussi un moyen de se
racheter une virginité auprès de la
population qui n'a plus beaucoup
confiance en fait dans la communication
officielle dans la mesure où pendant
très longtemps le régime a nié le
problème la minimiser
avec enneigement finalement la circulade
la formation de circuler librement ce
qui a entravé aussi la capacité du
système sanitaire chinois à faire face à
la propagation du virus
donc moi je pense que ça je trouve que
cet épisode est assez intéressant des
caractéristiques assez perverse des
régimes autoritaires et dictatoriaux
c'est-à-dire très longtemps quand on
parlait de la fin l'histoire et qu'on me
disait que finalement le modèle de
civilisation libérale était le plus à
même à traiter des problématiques de
notre temps certaines voix nous disait
on a gardé la chine ça fonctionne bien
c'est certes un régime autoritaire mais
l'inhumanité du de ce régime a le mérite
de coexister avec certaine efficacité
bien ce que cet épisode monde sait que
finalement l'autre l'autoritarisme même
pour la gestion des crises des plus
urgente n'est pas toujours efficace
parce que le monopole que le régime
détient sur l'information est un
obstacle à la résilience et à la
discipline des populations et en plus de
cela c'est un système où et comment il
ya une irresponsabilité totale c'est à
dire que tous ceux qui aujourd'hui sont
responsables de ce fiasco ne rendront
pas des deux de compte
là où dans un processus constitutionnel
ouvert les responsabilités et les têtes
tomberaient plus facilement pardonnez
moi je trouve pas que ça soit un fiasco
par rapport à ce qu'ils ont fait
complètement d'accord avec vous sur la
question politique de la chine et c'est
à ça et puis ils ont réussi à résoudre
grâce à cette épidémie la crise à hong
kong
d'accord oui il est carrément il a
notamment réussi enfin le gouverneur
local s'est tu pendant mais cela dit on
peut pas dire que ce soit un fiasco
parce que justement ils ont réussi quand
même à faire une barrière et a passé et
le travail qui est cohérent deuil où il
serait une véritable dictature ferme et
s'ils collaboraient pahor il collabore
ils ont vraiment un livre ouvert
ouais mais en même le des experts de msf
sur le oui mais ça y est ça y est c'est
fait mais c'est lorsque son voile à
cesser leur culture vous savez très bien
comment ils sont
c'est pénible s'est dit je suis
démocrate alors pu se permettre d'enfin
recouru à 87 à traîner les choses
alors une fois rethel mis plus de temps
ici a bloqué 20 millions de personnes
bah oui euh euh ils sifflent comment
débloquer et pas chez soi là là ils ont
réussi à faire la barrière qu'on me
serais incapable de faire en voir oui
parce que sans vouloir je vais pas
parler à sa place mais rappelez-vous en
2003 quand certains médecins disaient je
crois que c'est la merde dans les
hôpitaux parlant d'être grossier il ya
un problème il fait trop chaud et les
personnes âgées sont en train de mourir
le pouvoir en place lui faisait des
conférences de presse assurée puisque
parce qu'il fait ce ministre en bras de
chemise a communiqué en disant non mais
tout va bien
un médecin sur place forcément on va
dire tout et n'importe quoi sur ces
sujets là c'est extrêmement complexe
parce que il faut que la la mécanique
générale se sont responsabilisés
à chaque étape pour véritablement
engrangé un processus de groupe et c'est
ça qui est compliqué et on n'était pas
très bon jusqu'à 2003 un dernier mot
là-dessus patrick pleau olympe dg nous
dit ça n'a aucun sens de comparer la
grippe normale au coronavirus parce que
nous n'avons pas encore de bilan annuel
c'est vrai que du coronavirus peut-être
que dans un an le corona violente mais
plus que les bons parce que les
pourcentages je suis pas d'accord avec
olympe les pourcentages qu'on a parce
que vous imaginez tout le monde
réfléchit par rapport aux personnes
contaminées à leur mortalité et la
mortalité moins forte que la grippe
saisonnière
oui ok sur la même sur les mêmes sur les
nouvelles malgré à 17,7 votre auditrice
a tout à fait raison n'a pas les
chiffres
au final mais pour l'instant c'est moins
virulent que et comme le sujet passionne
le virus continue t-il à muter nous
demande claudio 60e c'est bien ça vient
mais quel mauvaise question mais en même
temps c'est à dire que c'est désespérant
par bruxelles
il ya des choses qu'on ne sait pas quand
on va là il faut le dire voilà on change
de sujet est complètement si vous le
voulez bien on va reparler de millas
vous avez cette jeune lycéenne qui a
exprimé sur les réseaux sociaux sont son
compte instagram pour être précis une
détestation très très violente et assez
vulgaire il faut bien le dire de l'islam
depuis
les responsables publics sont assez
divisés sont-ils ou ne sont ils pas mis
là on se souvient des déclarations de
ségolène royal expliquant qu'elle
n'était vraiment pas du tout mais la
voici deux nouvelles prises de positions
qui sont intéressantes puisque ne
viennent pas du même camp politique
écoutez d'abord brice hortefeux l'ancien
ministre de nicolas sarkozy considérait
hier sur bfm tv que milla avait vraiment
été trop agressif pour être défendu les
propos de cette adolescente et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut en même temps se
souvenir que c'est une jeune fille qui
ces propos sont inutilement inutilement
agressif et injurieux elle elle se fait
traiter quand même la sollicite
notamment de sales plus de français
maths [ __ ] mais bien sûr c'est mais
ses propos étaient inutilement agressif
et donges et injurieux alors ça
n'empêche pas brice hortefeux de
condamner très très clairement est très
fermement les attaques dont elle fait
l'objet mais en tout cas il ya une
espèce de mise à distance
et puis écouter peut-être